this is your average all-in-one inkjet
printer i'm not
average i'm brother mfc
j eight eight
uh nine there are a lot of things to
hate about printers
but the constant running out of
expensive ink is pretty up there
michelin star magenta ah this tastes so
good because it's 50 dollars
and this is why you should never buy a
cartridge inkjet printer
ever again wait what printers
especially inkjet printers have been
destroying our lives
well forever these cartridges are always
running out of ink and then cost a small
fortune
to replace so i went in search of a
solution over the last few weeks i've
tested
10 different printers because well i
love printers
and i hate printers it's complicated
look there is no such thing as a great
printer there are only tolerable
printers
but in testing all of these i concluded
that if you're in the market for a new
printer
you should get a laser printer or a
relatively new type of printer called an
ink tank printer
here's why and the best ones to get hey
maybe you want to stop
watching this video what about friends
go watch an episode of friends let's
start with the inktank printers
this is the epson ecotank et2760
and while it might look like a regular
old inkjet printer
it has one major difference it holds a
lot of
ink inside it no old school cartridges
included in the box are bottles of ink
which the company says will last you up
to two years
so when you first set this up you fill
up these tanks here with the assigned
ink
it's pretty easy and not as messy as
you'd expect and the final
cyan the ink only comes out when placed
on this mechanism
here the ink then once the tanks are
full
you can start printing and printing and
printing
and printing yeah but can it fax
now here's the great part of this gone
are the days of constantly
monitoring your ink and replacing with
expensive cartridges
let's do some math because math and
printers
what a thrilling combination take this
regular epson workforce
inkjet printer it costs a hundred and
fifty dollars
its black ink cartridge costs twenty
dollars
and this color package cost thirty four
dollars
so fifty four dollars really for all of
it
now look at the yield the fancy printer
term for the number of pages
you get about 350 black pages and 240
color pages
now let's look back at the epson ink
tank cost
the printer costs 300 the ink in there
can print up to 7 500 black pages
and 6 000 color pages to print that
amount with the old school epson
inkjet you need to buy more than 20
something of those cartridges
which would cost you more than a
thousand dollars
i'm thinking 150 more for the printer up
front makes a lot more sense
especially if you print a lot and the
replacement ink bottles when you do
eventually run out
are super cheap thirteen dollars to
twenty 20 a bottle
all the major printer makers make ink
tank printers now
i tested one from each company and liked
the brother ink vestment
and the epson eco tank the best and by
best i mean they get my tolerable
printer award
brother doesn't require you to fill the
ink yourself it comes in these
well i won't call them cartridges which
is nice
it also had slightly nicer print quality
than the epson and it had a touchscreen
but it doesn't come with as much ink as
the apps in
i bet none of them tell you which way to
put in the glossy photo paper
by the way all of these are all in ones
meaning you get a printer
scanner and copier all in one
are you sure you don't want to fax now
an inktank really only makes sense if
you need color
but if you only really want to print in
black and white there's another option
a laser printer one of these is best if
you just want to print black and white
really really fast take this 170
brother hll2395dw
it printed the first 50 pages of the
nasa apollo 11 flight plan in one minute
and 36 seconds
look at this look at this nice photo of
these guys this hp i tested
took a minute longer and all those
inktank printers
took at least four minutes slow but
steady
wins the race i read that on pinterest
but toner for a laser printer isn't
cheap it costs 77
for the toner for this brother which has
a yield of 3 000 pages
and go back to that epson ink tank again
and you'll remember that included
7 500 black pages in the 300
price of the printer so if you want to
go the laser route this brother is my
top choice
oh brother
so there you have it a few good printers
to buy
and the end of printers taking all your
money and
all your cartridges you're always saying
control p command p hey
you try to control p at my age my
prostate isn't exactly what it used to
be